I got a lot of things to do,
and I need my memory to do it.
Reggie, I'm old,
and I seem like I can't remember
nothing no more.
I try to say what day it is.
I ain't got a clue.
Hey!
-Coy!
-A car--
What you doing, Unc?
So, you want me to take you
to that special doctor?
One that might could help you
remember things.
Is Reggie coming later?
No, it's just you and me.
But Reggie did want you
to go see this doctor, so...
We developed a treatment.
Mr. Grey will remember everything
that he has ever known.
But the treatment will only work once.
Is that what you want?
I got a lot of things to do,
and I need my memory to do it.
Mr. Grey!
How you feeling?
Never better. And that's a fact.
I can see it all so clear now.
My mind... there's a whole lifetime
just spinning around in there.
My uncle Coydog stole something.
Treasure.
I'm gonna find it.
Papa Grey, I'm worried about you.
The rate of the decline is accelerating.
Meaning my mind gonna be
worse than it was before?
But I got to finish this.
You got to let the river take its course.
And the river know
right where it's going.